Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zu Ausgabe Nummer 38 unserer Serie über wissenschaftliches Arbeiten und wissenschaftliche Arbeiten. Und heute möchten wir mal in einen Themenbereich, den wir interessanterweise noch so überhaupt gar nicht in den Fokus genommen haben, der aber natürlich auch nicht uninteressant ist, und zwar das Recht. Un dabei wollen wir eine spezifische historische Perspektive einnehmen und zurückblicken auf eine Zeit des Wandels, konkret das Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs. Um zu schauen, wie eigentlich so ein komplizierter Apparat, wie das juristische System in Deutschland ja auch schon damals war, umgeht mit Krisen, umgeht mit Wandel, umgeht mit großen Einschnitten in der gesellschaftlichen Entwicklung und zunächst einmal begrüße ich dazu meinen Gesprächspartner, nämlich Benjamin Lahusen, schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Herzlich Willkommen bei Forschergeist. Vielleicht mal erst mal zu Ihnen, Sie sind Wissenschaftler. Konkret wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter an der Humboldt-Universität in Berlin, also bei der juristischen Fakultät, das liegt ja nahe. Wie sind Sie denn da hingekommen in diesen Bereich? Was bringt einen denn dazu, überhaupt sich mit Jura zu beschäftigen?
Ja wenn ich das sagen könnte in einem Satz. Das ist eine schwierige Frage. Sie hatten angefangen mit der Einleitung, ich wäre Wissenschaftler, da würden glaube ich viele Juristen schon ins Grübeln kommen, ob sie eigentlich Wissenschaftler sind. Natürlich ist die offizielle Bezeichnung so Rechtswissenschaft und so studiert man auch Rechtswissenschaft. Aber ob das Recht eine Wissenschaft ist, ist schon lange umstritten. Und ich würde sagen, nein. Deswegen wäre ich schon skeptisch …
Wirklich, aber kommen da nicht wissenschaftliche Methoden zum Einsatz?
Doch die kommen zum Einsatz, aber nur in bestimmten Segmenten, zum Beispiel in der Rechtsgeschichte. Die Rechtsgeschichte ist sicher eine Wissenschaft, wenn man so will, die Beobachterfächer, die Grundlagenfächer, die sind Wissenschaft. Die dogmatischen Fächer meiner Meinung nicht. Die sind auf Entscheidung gepolt und auf praktisches Handeln und wenn sich ein Wissenschaftler unter Entscheidungszwang sieht, dann kann er eigentlich kein Wissenschaftler mehr sein. Dann ist er ein …
Also wen man sozusagen ausübender Jurist ist?
Jaja genau. Aber an der Universität findet viel statt, das die Ausübung des juristischen Berufes überhaupt erst ermöglicht. Und diese Bereiche würde ich wahrscheinlich aus dem Terminus der Wissenschaft hinausnehmen. Aber das müssen wir jetzt an der Stelle jedenfalls nicht vertiefen, das war nur Ihr Einstieg, weil Sie gesagt hatten, ich wäre Wissenschaftler.
Ja finde ich aber nicht so uninteressant. Weil ich gerade Jura als einen Bereich wahrnehme, der halt extrem von Formalitäten geprägt ist und damit eben auch von klarer Sprache. Man definiert, man muss unterscheiden, man muss Begrifflichkeiten sehr konkret fassen, um überhaupt daraus Schlüsse zu ziehen. Und diese Abstraktion gesellschaftlicher Vorgänge, die ja in dem Zusammenhang stattfindet und die daraus sich auch eigene ableitende Logik, empfinde ich schon als etwas wissenschaftliches ein Stück weit.
Ja.
Zumindest bei der Grundlage.
Doch ein Stück weit kann man das auf jeden Fall so sagen. Die Abstraktion, die Begriffsbildung, der Versuch zu generalisieren, zu universalisieren aus bestimmten Einzelphänomenen, das hat schon was wissenschaftliches. Aber ich würde sagen, dass ein anderer Teil, der für die Wissenschaft ganz wesentlich ist, eigentlich verloren geht, nämlich das Abwägen und das Für und Wider. Das hat man im Juristischen auch, aber die Kodierung ist eine sozusagen Ja-Nein-Kodierung. Man muss am Ende eine Frage beantworten und einen Anspruch zusprechen oder absprechen. Die Klage eben abweisen oder nicht. Das ist bei uns sehr spezifisch zugeschnitten auf die Vorstellung eines Richters, der sitzt und entscheidet und der kann dann nicht ein bisschen entscheiden und sagen, ja gut beide Seiten haben Argumente für sich und gegen sich, also teile ich mal die ganze Sache und geb jedem die Hälfte, das geht eigentlich nicht. Das geht im Zivilrecht vielleicht noch ein bisschen, im Strafrecht geht das eigentlich gar nicht. Da müssen Zweifel, die ja immer bleiben, unterdrückt werden und gehen unter in dieser eben binären Kodierung ja oder nein.
Ja gut, das haben die Physiker natürlich auch. Also vielleicht mal von der Quantenmechanik abgesehen.
Da kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Aber was vielleicht fehlt ist dieser Beweis, dieses beweisorientierte.
Ja das Beweisorientierte. Also mir kommt es immer so vor, als wäre das dogmatische Arbeiten im Recht, also das Arbeiten in den Kernfächern Zivilrecht, Strafrecht, öffentliches Recht und so weiter sehr stark ausgerichtet auf die Entscheidungssituation des Richters. Das hängt damit zusammen, dass unsere juristische Ausbildung einen vorbereiten soll auf den Beruf des Richters, obwohl die allermeisten den Beruf dann später gar nicht ausüben, aber das ist aus historischen Gründen eben so gewachsen, dass wir eine richterorientierte Ausbildung haben, die auf eine Entscheidung hinausläuft und diese Situation hat man in den Grundlagenfächern nicht. Dort kann man sich wirklich freie Reflexion sozusagen erlauben. Da können die Gedanken schwirren in alle Richtungen und können dahinfliegen, man kann Entscheidungen offen lassen, man kann Dinge andeuten oder sagen, an der Stelle sind gute Argumente dafür und gute dagegen, deswegen kann ich die Entscheidung nicht treffen und lass es offen oder spreche eine Ergebnis aus, eine Salvatorische Klausel, die dann eben genauso klingt, ein einerseits, ein andererseits bleibt übrig.
Die Aporie der Welt kann nicht aufgelöst werden. Und das ist eine Form der Distanznahme, die man in den Grundlagenfächern im Recht hat, in den Kernfächern meiner Meinung nach aber eigentlich nicht. Und deswegen gut kann man sich dann wieder darüber unterhalten, ob das nicht dem Wissenschaftsbegriff ohnehin inhärent ist, diese Offenheit, dass man das in den anderen Disziplinen auch hat. Letztendlich ist es dann vielleicht eine Frage der rhetorischen Strategie, wie man da vorgeht. Das wäre dann eigentlich nur gar nicht so wichtig. Aber ich würde wahrscheinlich sagen, die dogmatischen Fächer, so wie ich die wahrnehme, haben eher was zu tun mit einer Kunst, einer Kunsttechnik vielleicht.
Was deckt dogmatische Fächer konkret ab?
Also die Arbeit am geltenden Recht. Also die Arbeit am Zivilrecht, am BGB, Auslegungen, Versuch daraus …
Das nennt man dogmatisch?
Das nennt man im Recht Dogmatik genau. Im Recht und in der Theologie. Was auch eine interessante Parallele ist.
Glaubensfragen.
Jaja na klar, in die Richtung geht es dann, Glaubensfragen genau, ja.
Ja aber warum Jura? Warum überhaupt diesen Weg einschlagen?
Bei mir in der Familie sind die meisten zuständig für entweder weltliches oder göttliches Recht. Das heißt viele sind entweder Juristen oder Theologen. Und ich habe mich dafür nie besonders interessiert und fand das immer irgendwie trocken und lebensfremd und irgendwie abstoßend. Also ganz im Wortsinne abstoßend, es hat mich eben nicht angezogen. Und es hat sich dann irgendwann geändert, als die Frage dann konkret wurde, was ich eigentlich studieren will und ist gewichen einer ganz diffusen Vorstellung, dass Dienst an der Gerechtigkeit eine schöne Sache wäre. Und dass ein Jurastudium diesen Dienst irgendwie befördern könnte. Die erste Prämisse würde ich heute natürlich auch noch mittragen. Dienst an der Gerechtigkeit ist eine schöne Sache. Die zweite, dass Jurastudium da irgendwas zu beitragen, die ist dann schon sehr viel schwieriger. Ob das Recht irgendwas mit Gerechtigkeit zu tun hat und in welchem Sinne. Jedenfalls habe ich es mir damals so vorgestellt und habe dann gedacht, es wäre irgendwie gut Jura zu studieren.
Und die andere Neigung, die ich da so hatte, die ging so in künstlerische, musikalische, musische Richtungen, und das wäre aber dann ohnehin alles irgendwie brotlos gewesen und zwecklos, ziellos. Deswegen habe ich mich da beim Jurastudium eigentlich gut aufgehoben gefühlt.
Aber so richtig ohne Brotlosigkeit geht das auch nicht, wenn man sich dann für so eine akademische Karriere entscheidet?
Ja also die Brotlosigkeit war jetzt auch nicht das ausschlaggebende Kriterium. So strategisch hätte ich damals nie gedacht und werde auch nicht so strategisch denken, die Dinge ergeben sich eben. Die akademische Welt ist eine sehr schöne, mitunter eine sehr prekäre, aber irgendwie kommt man da auch durch. Also im Moment jedenfalls kann ich mich gar nicht beklagen, das ist eine sehr schöne Sache da.
Was für Etappen waren das dann in der Ausbildung so?
Ich habe in Tübingen angefangen zu studieren. Das war damals recht nahe am Heimatort und da war ich eben noch aus verschiedenen Gründen dem Heimatort verbunden. Bin dann relativ schnell in die Schweiz gegangen, nach Lausanne, da wollte ich immer hin, weil es mir am Genfer See so gut gefallen hat. Das war auch sehr schön. Ein Sommer da am See in den Schweizer Bergen.
Das ist hübsch da.
Ja das ist sehr hübsch. Und dann wollte ich aber eigentlich immer nach Berlin und deswegen direkt danach hier an die Humboldt-Uni gegangen. Die Humboldt-Uni hatte damals ein Austauschprogramm neu ins Leben gerufen mit der Columbia-University in New York und weil ich irgendwie da auch gerne hin wollte, habe ich mich da beworben und habe dann diesen Platz bekommen und bin dann nach New York, war da zwei Semester. Bin dann wieder zurück nach Berlin und habe hier mein Staatsexamen gemacht. Und wie es sich dann so ergibt, habe ich im Studium ein Seminar belegt bei meinem späteren Doktorvater, von dem ich dann sehr angetan, geradezu begeistert, mitgerissen war, das fand ich wirklich großartig, was da gemacht wurde. Also was heißt, wir sind uns näher gekommen, ich bin ihm näher gekommen und konnte dann immer wieder mit ihm arbeiten. Er war lange Direktor am MPI für europäische Rechtsgeschichte, am Max-Planck-Institut für europäische Rechtsgeschichte in Frankfurt. Und hatte dann gefragt, ob ich da nicht promovieren will und konnte mir dort auch eine Stelle verschaffen. Und deswegen war ich dann drei Jahre Doktorand am MPI in Frankfurt.
Das heißt da ging das eigentlich erst los, sich konkret für die Rechtsgeschichte zu interessieren?
Ja. Das ging dort erst los, wenn auch sehr zögerlich. Als ich da angefangen habe, habe ich mich für die Rechtsgeschichte eigentlich überhaupt nicht interessiert, sondern nur für die Rechtstheorie. Also für rechtsphilosophische, rechtstheoretische, rechtssoziologische Fragestellungen, die aber fast alle in der Gegenwart ihren Ausgangspunkt hatten und auch nur die Gegenwart behandelt haben. Und richtig historisch angereichert wurde das tatsächlich dann erst ganz allmählich während der Arbeit dort am Institut. Einfach weil ich umgeben war von Kollegen, die alle historisch gearbeitet haben. Und weil ich irgendwie immer mehr diesen empirischen Reichtum geschätzt habe, den da die Geschichte bietet. Da bleibt es dann häufig nicht so blutleer, was man da in der Gegenwart so vor sich hin theoriselt, sondern man kann das dann immer zeigen und anschaulich machen und das hat mir irgendwie gut gefallen.
Man versteht vielleicht auch erst, warum bestimmte Dinge so sind wie sie sind.
Ja. Also die Dinge bekommen einen ganz anderen Unterbau und Überbau zugleich. Und das hat mir gut gefallen. Deswegen habe ich da immer weiter versucht, mich der Geschichte anzunähern und die irgendwie aufzusaugen und dann habe ich hier mein zweites Staatsexamen gemacht, in Berlin dann wieder, also den juristischen Vorbereitungsdienst mit dem anschließenden Assessorexamen, was dann zu dem schönen Titel Volljurist führt, der glaube ich aber kein offizieller ist, aber ich führe ihn trotzdem sehr gern an, Volljurist. Als Distinktionsmerkmal gegenüber dem Juristen, der eben nur das erste Staatsexamen hat, also ich bin ein Volljurist.
Der Halbjurist.
Der Halbjurist ja. Und dann war es ein Zufall, dass die Uni Rostock damals eine Stelle ausgeschrieben hatte für einen wissenschaftlichen Mitarbeiter, der sich jedenfalls laut Stellenbeschreibung nur um Rechtsgeschichte und Rechtsphilosophie zu kümmern hätte. Und das hat mir sehr gut gefallen, die Aussicht, mich mit dem geltenden Recht gar nicht abgeben zu müssen, sondern nur Grundlagenfächer da vertreten zu dürfen und deswegen habe ich mich da beworben und bin dann eben nach Rostock gegangen. War da einige Jahre und dann hat sich die Möglichkeit ergeben, zurückzugehen nach Berlin.
Ist dann auch so ein bisschen so eine Flucht aus diesen Zwängen des täglichen Juristendaseins?
Nein das kann ich so nicht sagen.
Aber so eine gewisse Entzauberung höre ich jetzt schon raus?
Ja gut, Entzauberung natürlich. Wenn man antritt für den Dienst an der Gerechtigkeit und dann irgendwann den Verwaltungsakt in all seinen Spielarten kennenlernt, dann muss man fliehen ja. Also das juristische Studium ist in gewisser Weise eine Form der professionellen Verblödung. Also man muss schon sehr viele Dinge ausblenden, also technisieren und in Verwaltungssprache übertragen. Deswegen sage ich Verblödung, das ist natürlich polemisch ausgedrückt, aber meint, dass sehr viele Aspekte des Lebens verformt werden irgendwie. Und das kann einem liegen, mir liegt es eigentlich nicht so, deswegen brauche ich da bestimmte Formen des Ausgleiches. Die Rechtsgeschichte bietet so einen Ausgleich. Jetzt was die konkrete Station da in Rostock angeht, da kann ich jetzt nicht direkt von Flucht sprechen, das war einfach schön und hat sich so ergeben.
Flucht nach vorne.
Ja eine Flucht nach vorne.
Und dann war es die Rechtsgeschichte, die auf einmal in den Mittelpunkt rückte.
Ja.
Und das war dann auch der Ort, wo die Doktorarbeit geschrieben wurde?
Nein die war da schon fertig.
Ach die war schon fertig.
Die habe ich dann in Frankfurt geschrieben und dann hier in Berlin schon eingereicht und verteidigt gehabt.
Das heißt die hat sich auch noch nicht so sehr mit Geschichte beschäftigt?
Doch die hat sich dann selber historisiert im Laufe des Prozesses. Die habe ich angefangen eigentlich mit theoretischen Vorstellungen über das Recht, weitgehend inspiriert von Luhmann und der Systemtheorie. Und dann ist mir irgendwann aufgegangen, dass es viel schlüssiger wäre, die empirische Unterfütterung aus der Geschichte zu gewinnen und die Geschichte daraufhin nochmal abzuklopfen oder die Geschichte neu zu sortieren. Naja neu, so neu ist es auch nicht. Aber die Geschichte zu sortieren, anhand der Begrifflichkeiten der Luhmannschen Systemtheorie. Und deswegen war der Ausgangspunkt ein ganz gegenwartsbezogener und eben theoretischer, der eben im Laufe der Arbeit daran dann immer historischer geworden ist.
Ja und dann kam es zu einer interessanten Spezialisierung. Es gab eine Auseinandersetzung mit einem ganz konkrete Teil der deutschen Geschichte und damit halt auch der deutschen Rechtsgeschichte oder eher andersrum. Erst mal stand glaube ich die Rechtsgeschichte im Vordergrund und damit deckt man dann quasi einen interessanten Teil der deutschen Geschichte ab, nämlich konkret das Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs. Warum und worum ging es da?
Das ist ein Nebenprodukt des Referendariats. Das juristische Referendariat habe ich als wirklich die armseligste Zeit des ganzen Studiums oder der ganzen Ausbildung empfunden. Also das war furchtbar, intellektuell wirklich grauenhaft. Und da saß ich in meiner Not im Amtsgericht Lichtenberg herum und wusste nicht aus noch ein, in 3,5 stündigen Sitzungen Zivilprozessordnung hoch und runter, wie man Klagen zustellt in Plattenbauten, wo drei Leute Müller heißen und so was. Das habe ich als wirklich schrecklich in Erinnerung und habe dann, weil mir gar nichts anderes mehr eingefallen ist, was ich da noch machen könnte, durch meine Gesetzessammlung geblättert. Was wirklich Ausdruck dann tiefer Verzweiflung ist, wenn man da aus Langeweile da in der ZPO blättert. Und da bin ich irgendwann auf einen Paragraphen gestoßen, den ich nicht kannte, nämlich 245 der Zivilprozessordnung. Der heißt Unterbrechung durch Krieg oder so ähnlich.
Und da steht sinngemäß drin, dass im Falle eines Krieges alle Gerichtsverfahren, die gerade anhängig sind, also im Zivilrecht, unterbrochen werden und weitergehen sollen, wenn der Krieg vorbei ist. Das fand ich schon einen ganz bemerkenswerten Satz, mit dem ich nicht gerechnet hatte. Ich wusste nicht, das sowas in der Zivilprozessordnung geregelt ist. Der hat aber in der Gesetzessammlung noch eine Fußnote und da steht ein Hinweis auf das Zuständigkeitsergänzungsgesetz vom 07. August 1952, das die Übernahme von Prozessen regelt, die an Gerichten anhängig waren am 8. Mai 45, an deren Sitz deutsche Gerichtsbarkeit nicht mehr ausgeübt wird. Das heißt konkret also in den verlorenen Ostgebieten. Vor allem da natürlich Olpen an der die???. Die Gebiete, die weggefallen sind, nach der bedingungslosen Kapitulation hatten natürlich auch Gerichte und Verfahren anhängig waren, konnte ab 52 im westdeutschen Bundesgebiet weitergeführt werden. So steht es da drin.
Und das hat mich schon bei der ersten Lektüre wirklich elektrisiert, weil ich das überhaupt nicht für möglich gehalten hatte, und gedacht hatte, es kann doch überhaupt nicht sein, da war doch alles kaputt, da können gar keine Verfahren mehr anhängig gewesen sein, da war doch das ganze Leben dahin. So jedenfalls hatte ich das irgendwie mal gelernt, auch erzählt bekommen von den Großeltern, die einem dann immer das gleiche von den Bombennächten, wie alles furchtbar war.
Ausnahmezustand.
Wirklich so der totale Ausnahmezustand, so hatte ich das vor Augen und dann wird mir da im Gesetz erzählt, wer da eine Klage anhängig hatte, der kann die natürlich dann mitnehmen und im Westen irgendwie weiterführen. Und das hat mich wirklich elektrisiert und da habe ich da im Referendariat schon gedacht, in dieser Sitzung, die ich da noch auszuhalten hatte, da muss ich irgendwie mal dem nachgehen, wie so was denn konkret nun eigentlich ausgesehen haben soll. Dass da wirklich ein Verfahren im Dritten Reich beginnt und dann in der Nachkriegszeit weitergeführt wird. Und das habe ich dann, also das war der Ausgangspunkt, die Initialzündung und dann habe ich angefangen, alle Archive anzuschreiben und die nach und nach alle zu besuchen.
Und dann was herauszufinden?
Um zunächst einmal herauszufinden, ob es solche Verfahren tatsächlich gegebne hat, also auf welches konkrete Problem diese Gesetzgebung von 1952 dann geantwortet hat. Warum in der Zivilprozessordnung dieses Problem angesprochen wird und irgendwie eine abstrakt generellen Regelung zugeführt wird, was soll so was, wieso haben wir so was? Und um dann irgendwann diese Akten zu studieren, in der Hoffnung, dort irgendwie wiederzufinden, wie diese Umbruchssituation der bedingungslosen Kapitulation, Untergang des deutschen Reiches und so weiter und so fort sich auf diesen konkreten Rechtsakten abzeichnet, wie die sich dort widerspiegelt, wie die da verarbeitet wird, das wollte ich herausfinden.
Wen haben Sie da angeschrieben? Also wonach wählt man das dann aus? Wie viele Archive gibt es da überhaupt?
Da git es sehr viele, dank des deutschen Föderalismus gibt es eine riesige Vielzahl von Archiven. Für die Justizakten sind auf der Ebene die Landesarchive zuständig. Da gibt es in jedem Bundesland im Prinzip eins. In aller Regel ist es aber nicht ein Haus, sondern regional dann nochmal aufgesplittert. Also man hat dann vielleicht, ich weiß es nicht, 25-30 Archive irgendwie so was. Und ich habe die nicht jetzt alle 30, doch angeschrieben habe ich sie wahrscheinlich alle, in der irrigen Meinung, dass die selber wüssten, so genau, was sie eigentlich besitzen. Das weiß ich jetzt heute etwas besser oder kann das besser einschätzen, dass es keinen Sinn hat, denen so eine offene Frage zu stellen, sondern man da schon konkreter denen Anhaltspunkte liefern muss, wonach man denn nun eigentlich sucht. Und dann wiedermal ganz lebensweltlich dirigiert habe ich in dem Archiv angefangen zu suchen, wo ich eine kostenlose Unterkunft hatte, nämlich in der Nähe meiner Eltern im Staatsarchiv Ludwigsburg.
Und was kam dann zutage?
Da kam zutage, also die hatten mir vier Archivalien genannt, die unter meine Kriterien fallen. Die habe ich mir dann alle bestellt, habe dann dort vor Ort bei der Recherche in den Findbüchern festgestellt, dass es tatsächlich dutzende wenn nicht hunderte Akten sind, die da einschlägig sind. Eben weil die Archive da auf der Ebene das auch nicht für jede Archivalie nun genau wissen können, was sie da haben. Und bei der inhaltlichen Analyse, dass sich dieser Umbruch in den Akten überhaupt gar nicht widerspiegelt.
Also nochmal zur Verdeutlichung, zunächst ging quasi die erste Recherche ganz konkret auf Zivilprozesse, die in irgendeiner Form durch das Kriegsende unterbrochen wurden?
Genau.
Und die wurden auch unterbrochen oder war das nur so eine Unterbrechung, weil Staat ist zusammen gefallen, nächsten Montag geht es weiter? Oder waren da Wochen, Monate oder Jahre dazwischen?
Ach schon das lässt sich fast nicht generell beantworten. Bei manchen sind tatsächlich Jahre dazwischen. Es gibt Gerichte, die fangen Ende der 40er an, 48/49, die Partei wieder anzuschreiben und die darauf aufmerksam zu machen, dass da noch Verfahren anhängig sind und sie die doch bitte weiterführen sollen. Dann schreiben manche zurück, dass es sich erledigt hat, dass der Kläger zwischenzeitlich verstorben ist, dass er im Krieg noch gefallen ist, irgendwie so was. Und andere schreiben zurück, endlich. Dann führe ich jetzt fort, bitte um Anberaumung eines Termins zur mündlichen Verhandlung. Also bei manchen sind es Jahre, bei manchen sind es Tage. Also es gibt tatsächlich ein Gericht, allerdings habe ich da bisher nur gefunden, von insgesamt etwa 2200, die es damals gegeben hat, also wirklich eine ganz krasse Ausnahme, die verhandeln ohne jede Unterbrechung. Die verhandeln im Mai 45, warum kann ich mir nicht genau erklären, ein Anwalt behauptet, sie hätten eine Sondergenehmigung der Alliierten bekommen, friedenswichtige Verfahren zu erledigen.
Und deswegen können die sich das wohl leisten, da schon im Mai 45 wieder tätig zu werden. Ganz generell waren alle Gerichte von den Alliierten geschlossen, mit dem Einmarsch der Alliierten waren die Gerichte geschlossen worden und deswegen ganz generell bei allen Gerichten war eine Unterbrechung eingetreten.
Aber es hieß ja, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, in diesem Paragraph 45, wenn Krieg herrscht, hat das eingestellt zu werden. Der hat ja nun nicht nur am 8. Mai geherrscht, sondern der hat ja auch schon vorher geherrscht. Ist denn vorher irgendwas eingestellt worden? Also wie disruptiv war denn sozusagen der Krieg tatsächlich für das Rechtswesen in Deutschland?
Mit Krieg ist darin nicht die Kriegserklärung gemeint. Das wird im Kommentar dann auch erläutert, dazu gibt es natürlich auch eine Kommentierung, die versucht, diesen Begriff etwas näher zu fassen. Die Kriegserklärung an sich genügt nicht, sondern es muss irgendeine Form von faktischer Unmöglichkeit eintreten. Und erst wenn die eintritt, wenn tatsächlich die Kriegshandlung so überragend wird und soweit eingreift ins tägliche Leben, dass man nicht mehr weiter arbeiten kann, dann tritt eine Unterbrechung durch den Stillstand der Rechtspflege ein. Das war auch so ein interessanter Punkt, weil ich eben in meinem etwa naiven Vorverständnis geglaubt hatte, dass die Zerstörung einer Stadt beispielsweise ausreichen würde, um den Stillstand der Rechtspflege einzuführen, das ist aber eben auch nicht so. Da gibt es dann ab Anfang 44 dann konkrete Anweisungen an die Gerichte, wie die da vorzugehen haben. Mit dem Tenor, dass sie doch bitte jede Unterbrechung vermeiden sollen.
Also nicht einfach nur, weil da gerade ein Großangriff oder wie man dann damals immer gesagt hat, ein Terrorangriff der Amerikaner stattgefunden hat, soll man aufhören zu arbeiten, sondern man soll bitte schön so lange weiter arbeiten, bis es denn überhaupt gar nicht mehr geht. Und das tun die auch. Das hat dann bei mir das Schwergewicht insgesamt etwas verlagert auf die letzten Kriegsmonate. Also die Frage der Zäsur ist dann darüber so etwas in den Hintergrund getreten und ich wollte zunächst mal eine genaue Bestandsaufnahme mir erarbeiten, was dann nun eigentlich bei deutschen Gerichten noch passiert ist. Und habe deswegen in großer Zahl offizielle Lagebericht, inoffizielle Lageberichte, die geheimen Lageberichte und so was zusammen gesammelt aus den verschiedenen Oberlandesgerichtsbezirken und da kann man das dann sehr schön sehen, die schildern nach Berlin letzte Nacht Zerstörung unserer Innenstadt, alle Gerichtsgebäude sind kaputt, alle Akten sind verbrannt, der Gerichtsbetrieb wurde nicht unterbrochen.
Wurde nicht unterbrochen?
Wurde nicht unterbrochen, das ist dann fast immer der letzte Satz in diesen Berichten.
Sondern?
Na in der Regel hatten die Notfallpläne, also wussten, was sie dann zu tun hätten. Haben sich dann schon überlegt nach den ersten großen Flächenbombardements, wie man damit umgehen würde. Dass man bestimmte Zuständigkeiten benennt im Personal, wer dann was zu tun hat, welcher Löschtrupp wo eingreift, aber auch welches Justizpersonal am Morgen danach bereitsteht, um irgendwo weiter zu judizieren. Und auch dieses Irgendwo ist dann schon vorher festgelegt, man hat Ausweichquartiere am Stadtrand, vielleicht in sozusagen befreundeten Verwaltungen. Dass man sagt, hier beim Landratsamt irgendwas, die haben sich bereit erklärt, die Kantine bereitzustellen oder irgendwie so was. Also Gasthöfe, Hotels, Sparkassen und so weiter werden dann häufig angemietet, aber das weiß man alles schon vorher. Da besteht ein Plan, wie man dann vorzugehen hat. Und als letzte Ingredienz braucht man dann immer noch die Akten und auch dafür bestehen Pläne. Also die Akten werden meistens ab 42 in Sicherheit gebracht.
Also entweder abgetippt, das passiert vor allem bei den Grundbüchern, in den Keller gebracht, wenn man einen hat, bombensicheren Keller, wenn es besonders gut ist, vielleicht sogar feuerfeste Schränke, das wäre dann ganz besonders gut. Oder man benennt auch für die Akten irgendwelche sicheren Einlagerungsorte an der Peripherie, bringt die dort hin und weiß, dass sie dort lagern und wenn die Gerichtsgebäude in der Stadt zerstört sind, dann werden die reaktiviert.
Das heißt der Datenverlust war gar nicht so groß, wie man vielleicht meinen möchte, wenn jetzt so ein komplettes Justizgebäude zerstört wird?
Nein der Datenverlust war nicht so groß. Da werden häufig Aktenserien verbrannt, das ist gar keine Frage, aber selbst dann lassen die sich in aller Regel nochmal rekonstruieren. Weil man eben vorher für Dubletten gesorgt hat. Weil ja von vielen Akten sowieso mehrere irgendwie zirkulieren. Bei Gerichtsakten hat man dann immer Schriftsätze bei den Anwälten, bei den Parteien meistens irgendwelche Kopien, vielleicht noch bei unteren Instanzen. Die kann man dann alle anschreiben, die schicken dann alles was sie haben und dann setzt man Gerichtsschreiber hin, die dann wochenlang damit beschäftigt sind, die Akten abzutippen.
Das ist ja bemerkenswert. Was denken Sie denn, was da sozusagen der primäre Antrieb gewesne ist? Reden wir jetzt hier von einem Auswuchs des ohnehin ja auf so vielen Ebenen frappierenden Wahnsinns der nationalsozialistischen Zeit, die sozusagen Krieg dann auch wirklich auf so vielen Ebenen durchdenkt, dass das auch das juristische System betrifft und entsprechend absichert? Oder ist das etwas, was aus diesem juristischen Betrieb selbst herauskommt und einfach Teil dieses Systems bereits ist?
Ich glaube letzteres. Ich glaube, das hat mit dem Nationalsozialismus eigentlich wenig zu tun, vielleicht sogar gar nichts. Wenn es Auswüchse sind, das wäre ja schon pejorativ irgendwie formuliert, wenn es Auswüchse sind, dann sind es Auswüchse der Bürokratie, die sich für alle Eventualitäten gewappnet hat und Schriften produziert, Akten produziert über andere Akten, darüber wo diese anderen Akten liegen, die kann man dann ständig ergänzen. Das sind übrigens sehr schöne Akten, die heute anzugucken, weil man das ja streng analog gemacht hat. Das heißt man hat dann Listen und überklebt die dann zum Umklappen und Wiederaufklappen, um die ergänzen zu können und weiter anbauen zu können. Das sind sehr schöne Akten, aber ich glaube nicht, dass die was mit dem Dritten Reich oder dem Nationalsozialismus zu tun haben, mit dem totalen Krieg, der überall hin durchdringt, sondern einfach bürokratische Eigenleistungen darstellen. Die man wahrscheinlich 20 Jahre zuvor genauso gefunden hätte und 20-30 Jahre danach, wahrscheinlich heute immer noch genauso.
Aber es ist schon ein deutsches Ding?
Das weiß ich nicht. Wenn Sie es ansprechen, ich muss der Frage mal nachgehen. Es liegt bei mir auch immer so nahe, daran irgendwie was deutsches zu sehen. Also das ist für mich natürlich auch der primäre Antrieb, weil ich selber halt auch ein Deutscher bin und der deutschen Kultur mich verbunden fühle oder der deutschen Geschichte und dann sehe ich immer da diese Biedermänner vor mir, die ihre unwichtigen Prozesse führen und diese Akten abtippen und denke immer, habt ihr denn nichts besseres zu tun? Und ich weiß natürlich, sie hätten sehr viel besseres zu tun gehabt. Aber haben sich mit diesem Besseren nicht auseinandersetzen wollen und haben dann eben sich vielleicht die Flucht, die ich nicht angetreten habe, vielleicht haben die die angetreten in ihre Akten und in die Normalität dieser bürokratisierten Welt. Aber um das mit anderen Ländern in Verbindung oder in Kontrast zu setzen, fehlt mir der Vergleich.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt in vollentwickelten Bürokratien wirklich anders aussähe. Ob dann in Frankreich oder in England in vergleichbaren Situationen wirklich anders gehandelt worden wäre und was dann eigentlich der Gewinn gewesen wäre, wenn man da anders gehandelt hätte. Also natürlich würde ich da häufig erwarten, dass in den Akten irgendwie mir dieses Grauen der Zeit entgegen springt, aber ich sehe es dann nirgendwo, aber vielleicht ist es auch gar nicht hilfreich. Vielleicht wäre es gar nicht hilfreich, wenn es einem dann entgegenbringt und wenn die überall auf jeder Seite was anmerken und sagen, ja heute ist wieder dies und jenes Furchtbare passiert, aber das lassen wir jetzt beiseite und gehen zurück zu unserer Akte, das würde ja eigentlich auch niemandem helfen. Aber ich weiß es nicht. Ich vermute allerdings, dass es dort ähnlich war oder ähnlich gewesen wäre, wenn es dort vergleichbare Situationen gegeben hätte.
Was ist denn nun tatsächlich passiert in dieser Zeit? Also lässt sich denn die Tatsache, dass im Prinzip ja Kreis stattfand, von herrschen will ich jetzt mal noch nicht reden, aus den Prozessen, mit denen sich die juristischen Entitäten dort beschäftigt haben, lässt sich das da herauslesen oder ist da irgendwie überhaupt gar kein Krieg abzubilden? Also ist da kein Krieg abgebildet? Findet das in irgendeiner Form da statt? Was entdeckt man, wenn man dann schaut?
Man entdeckt nicht den Krieg. Man entdeckt die Art und Weise, wie der Krieg als System irrelevante Umwelt, wenn ich das so luhmannianisch formulieren kann, hinwegfiktionalisiert wird, verbannt wird aus dem was einen interessiert, aus dem relevanten Kosmos. Der Krieg ist juristisch gesehen keine besonders aufregende Sache. Der ist eben Unterbrechungsgrund in der Zivilprozessordnung, den aber keiner kennt, weil er ja irgendwie auch kurios ist, was soll es, wenn alles kaputt ist, hören Gerichtsverfahren auf. Das hört sich ja wie eine ganz banale Selbstverständlichkeit an. Und genauso wird es auch behandelt. Man findet Hinweise auf den Krieg dann, wenn er Zerstörung bringt, also wenn man Akten rekonstruieren muss, ansonsten aber eigentlich nur dann, wenn der Krieg irgendwie verwendet werden kann als ein juristisches Argument. Also wenn man auf Postverzögerung verweisen kann, wenn die Kanzlei kaputt ist und man deswegen irgendwelche Fristen versäumt hat.
Ganz selten auch mal, dass jemand darauf hinweist, dass es im Krieg keine Mieterhöhung geben soll oder so was. Aber das sind Laienfantasien. Also das wäre wie wenn heute einer sagt, in der Finanzkrise gibt es keine Mieterhöhungen. Das sind so die letzten Trümpfe, kann man es nicht mal nennen, weil es eigentlich zu untauglich ist als Argument, die man zieht in einer ausweglosen Situation, aber ansonsten spielt der Krieg eine ganz ganz untergeordnete Rolle. Wirklich ein entferntes Rauschen im Hintergrund.
Und das obwohl es doch eine hohe Zahl an Todesfällen vor allem auch von jungen Leuten gibt. Das müsste ja doch schon auch eine Auswirkung haben oder nicht?
Na in den Akten, die ich untersuche, hat das eigentlich keine Auswirkungen. Die jungen Leute sind da nicht besonders präsent. WAs aber natürlich auch daran liegt, dass ich den Fokus sehr stark auf die letzten Kriegsjahre gerichtet habe und da jetzt von Wehrmachtssoldaten oder so keine Klagen mehr anhängig gemacht werden. Also dass da einer stirbt oder fällt, das kommt in meinen Akten selten vor. Auch bei dem Justizpersonal kommt das selten vor. Also da finden Sie natürlich hinweise, dass einer einberufen wird oder dass einer an der Front gefallen ist und man jetzt seiner gedenken möge. Aber wenn ein Richter weg ist, kommt halt ein anderer Richter. Das ist für das Verfahren dann eigentlich egal.
Das heißt in einer Zeit, in der man eigentlich denken möchte, alles ist anders, ist eigentlich alles ganz normal?
Das wäre plakativ formuliert, aber das ist einer der Befunde, zu denen ich gekommen bin. Und man kann nicht sagen, dass alles normal wäre. Der Ausschnitt, den ich betrachte, der ist normal. Und die Normalität gewinnt an Kraft, an Suggestivkraft und an Besonderheit, an Merkwürdigkeit natürlich nur dadurch, dass sie vor der Folie stattfindet einer totalen Unnormalität und eines totalen Ausnahmezustandes. Und dieses Nebeneinander interessiert mich. Und ich habe mir diesen einen Aspekt rausgesucht, einfach deshalb, weil ich der Ansicht bin, dass über den anderen schon sehr viel geschrieben ist und dass die Konzentration auf diesen anderen Aspekt eine gewisse Entfremdung verursacht hat. Man fühlt sich mit der Zeit nicht mehr verbunden, hakt die eben immer so ab und sagt, ja da kommt das Dritte Reich, da war alles dunkel und schlecht und böse. Und ab 45 ist man dann zurück wieder beim Licht.
Und jetzt weiß man natürlich auch, dass es so nicht stimmt und dass es 45 auch noch sehr lange gedauert hat, bis da wirklich ein gesellschaftlicher Umbruch stattgefunden hat. Aber ich konzentriere mich auf diesen normalen Aspekt, weil ich der Ansicht bin, dass es der ist, den wir mit der damaligen Zeit teilen. Damit kann man sich irgendwie verbinden, sich identifizieren. Wenn da Leute ihre normalen Nachbarschaftsstreitigkeiten weiterführen, dann denkt man, dass die vielleicht doch so waren wie wir. Dass wir also moralisch noch nicht so weit davon entfernt sind von der Zeit, wie wir manchmal gerne hätten.
Im Sinne von, dass man das alles ignoriert, was um einen rum passiert?
Dass man das alles ignoriert und eben immer abhakt und sagt, ja darüber wissen wir nun wirklich genug.
Das heißt man entdeckt eigentlich eine totale Normalität inmitten einer Zeit, in der man das vielleicht erst mal nicht erwarten würde?
Ja in dem Segment, was ich untersuche, entdeckt man eine totale Normalität. Die immer wieder Reminiszenzen an den Rest in sich birgt. Terminverschiebung, weil der Anwalt zum Volkssturm einberufen wurde und so weiter. Aber diese Einbrüche werden eben erst mal juristisch verpackt, dann hier umgerechnet in einen neuen Gerichtstermin oder sowas, neue Art der Prozessführung und wenn sie diese Verpackung erfahren haben, dann kann man sie zur Kenntnis nehmen.
Jetzt ist es ja so ein bisschen vorherrschende Methode von der Bundesrepublik, als Nachfolger des deutschen Reichs, zu sprechen als der Rechtsstaat. Das System, was jetzt sozusagen das Recht auch mal wieder auf eine ganz neue Ebene hebt. Das ist sicherlich was die Auswüchse des Nationalsozialismus betrifft auch klar der Fall, aber ich höre jetzt so ein bisschen raus, manches hat sich auch gar nicht so sehr geändert. Heißt das, dass das dann so unrechtsstaatlich in manchen Teilen gar nicht war?
Nein das heißt es nicht. Das sind unterschiedliche Ebenen. Was ich untersuche ist über weite Strecken das formale Funktionieren der Institutionen auf einer Ebene, auf der ihr wenig Möglichkeiten gegeben worden wären, sich unrechtsstaatlich zu betätigen. Die Ziviljustiz, die ich da untersuche, hat weitgehend zu tun eben mit Nachbarschaftsstreitigkeiten. Dort kann man auch rassische Diskriminierung unterbringen, das ist überhaupt keine Frage. Das findet in meinen Akten aber nicht mehr statt, weil sie in der Regel erst 43/44 beginnen. Dort hat man mit Ausgrenzung durch Recht wenig zu tun, einfach deshalb, weil schon alle ausgegrenzt sind. Ein Jude kann 43 kein Gerichtsverfahren mehr führen. Und deswegen ist dann für die Justiz auch keine Notwendigkeit, die noch irgendwie zu diskriminieren.
Wäre also sozusagen der Flasche Betrachtungsraum, um solche Schlüsse überhaupt erst mal ziehen zu können oder zu untersuchen.
Genau, das wäre der falsche Betrachtungsraum. Und in meinen Akten taucht natürlich auch eine riesige Vielzahl von Unrecht auf. Eben dann wenn ich ins Strafrecht überwechsle, vor allem ins politische Strafrecht, also zu den Sondergerichten, die ich auch untersucht habe, jedenfalls zum Teil. Und dieser Aspekt des Unrechts verschwindet jedenfalls teilweise. Volksschädlinge werden nach 1945 nicht mehr als solche benannt und nicht mehr als solche verurteilt. Das ist nicht möglich, weil die Alliierten es verboten haben und darauf auch sehen und das überwachen, dass solche Verfahren nicht mehr durchgeführt werden. Also bestimmte Formen der Politisierung, der politisierten Auswüchse verschwinden tatsächlich. Deswegen kann man das so nicht sagen, das ist keine Relativierung, dass die Zeit damals nicht so schlimm gewesen wäre oder ähnliches. Also mich interessiert da wirklich das formale Funktionieren der Institutionen, die offensichtlich bestimmte Dienstleistung erbringt, die einem wichtig sind, sie entscheidet nämlich Konfliktfälle in konkreten Fällen. Sie entscheidet Konfliktsituationen in konkreten Fällen.
Und dieses formale Funktionieren scheint derart wichtig zu sein für eine Gesellschaft, dass man es selbst in diesem totalen Ausnahmezustand durchhält und natürlich selbstverständlich davon heute auch noch Gebrauch macht.
Jetzt ich wollte ja damit auch nicht unterstellen, dass ich jetzt irgendwie die Vermutung habe, das wäre ja dann der tolle Rechtsstreit gewesen. Die Frage, die mich in dem Moment einfach beschäftigt hat, ist so, wie getrennt ist dieser Apparat von dem, was ihn unter Umständen von oben ideologisch steuert. Wenn wir jetzt über Nachbarschaftsstreitigkeiten reden, dann ist wahrscheinlich die Ideologie eher am Rande dann ein Thema, wenn überhaupt. Klingt ja jetzt erst mal auch ein bisschen langweilig. Also man hat sich jetzt sozusagen diese Zeit angeguckt, festgestellt, alles wie immer. Was ist sind sagen wir mal die überraschenden Erkenntnisse aus der Betrachtung dieser Zeit? Was kann man denn dann für Schlüsse daraus ziehen?
Für mich war schon die Erkenntnis, alles wie immer, überraschend. Ich hätte ehrlich gesagt damit nicht gerechnet. Ich hätte was anderes erwartet. Also Krieg als Gesellschaftszustand, totaler Krieg, der wirklich alle Bereiche der Gesellschaft erfassen soll, dass der auch aufs Rechtssystem weiter durchschlägt. Und auch dort Strukturen irgendwie verformt und verändert in einer viel tiefergehenden Art und Weise, als ich es bisher feststellen konnte. Also dieses, alles wie immer, fand ich schon sehr überraschend. Nein in anderen Bereichen bei Nachbarschaftsstreitigkeiten ist da in der Tat der Spielraum relativ begrenzt, eben sozusagen durch die Natur der Sache. Aber Ehestreitigkeiten, die sind natürlich in ganz anderer Weise dann ideologisch durchtränkt. Abstammungsprozesse, die damals noch geführt werden, Unterhaltsfragen. Das sind alles Verfahren, die bis zum Kriegsende durchgeführt werden, häufig aus ideologischen Gründen der Bevölkerungspolitik, der rassischen Reinheit und so weiter.
Da findet man natürlich den Krieg auch sehr viel weniger als man vielleicht denken würde, aber die Ideologie findet man da durchaus.
Was für Schlüsse haben Sie denn gezogen sozusagen aus dieser Betrachtung, also außer dass jetzt alles normal war? Was ist denn so die Eigenschaft dieser Normalität? Was lernt man daraus?
Die Normalität scheint ein wesentlicher Stabilisierungsfaktor für so eine Gesellschaft zu sein. Also die total Kriegführung wird nicht dadurch unterstützt, dass die Justiz sich auch im totalen Krieg irgendwie engagiert. Sondern eigentlich wird sie dadurch unterstützt, dass sich die Justiz in dem Segment dem totalen Krieg sozusagen entgegensetzt oder verweigert. Dass der dort eben gerade nicht stattfindet. Das heißt die Normalität in der Justiz ist eigentlich so was wie die Verwirklichung einer Logik vom totalen Krieg. Auf eine indirekte Art und Weise. Man unterstützt den, indem man gerade die Formen nicht zerschlägt und nicht dem Kriegsgeschehen anpasst. Weil es wohl für die beteiligten Akteure, für die Kläger, für die Parteien, aber auch für das Justizpersonal eine doch erheblich beruhigende Form der Daseinsbewältigung zu sein scheint, wenn man sich solchen Routinen anvertrauen kann.
Und da glaube ich auch, dass wir heute da nicht anders wären, wenn die Welt kaputt geht, wenn die Welt untergeht, dann ist es tröstlich, wenn wenigstens die U-Bahn pünktlich fährt. Und das ist dort irgendwie auch festzustellen auf ganz unterschiedlichen Ebenen. Die Justizjuristen haben häufig keine andere Wahl, die werden dann ab Februar 45 mit handfesten Drohungen begleitet, wer da zu früh von seinem Arbeitsplatz flieht im Angesicht des Feindes, wird vor den Volksgerichtshof gestellt und so was. Also die haben nicht direkt die Wahl. Die Parteien allerdings hätten sowohl die Wahl, keiner wird gezwungen einen Zivilprozess zu führen. Völlig sinnlose Titel, die man da erstreitet. Der Nachbar soll bitte raus aus der Wohnung, in die er eingewiesen wurde, weil seine eigene zerstört ist. Jeder weiß, dass ein Titel nichts nützt, weil der erst dann ausgewiesen wird, wenn er eine Ersatzwohnung hat, aber die gibt es nicht. Also hat man dann irgendwann ein gerichtlich verbrieftes Recht, dass er da raus muss, sobald er eine Ersatzwohnung hat und die wird eben dann in einigen Jahren fertig sein.
Aber das sind eigentlich völlig sinnlose Auseinandersetzungen, aber trotzdem scheint es die Leute irgendwie zu befriedigen, dass sie sich da in diesem Kommunikationsraum der Justiz bewegen, dort eine Protokollanten vorfinden, die gewöhnten Formulare, einen Gerichtsdiener, einen Pedell, Roben, Talare, Barette. Also irgendwie eine Welt, die so nicht mehr stattfinden dürfte, aber dort noch immer stattfindet.
Es ist also eine Stabilisierung der Gesellschaft durch aktiv gelebte Normalität? Um das mal so zu sagen.
Ja.
Wenn man jetzt mal nicht so sehr die Phase, als noch der Krieg war, betrachten, sondern die Phase unmittelbar danach, wo es dann deutlichere Zerstörung gab, enorme Flüchtlingsbewegung, die auch vorher schon eingesetzt haben, aber die ja dann nochmal in einem ganz anderen Maße sich abgespielt haben, weil dann ja irgendwie auch klar war, wo man bleiben kann, wo man nicht bleiben kann. Inwiefern war denn dann dieses juristische System unmittelbar nach dem Krieg in der Lage, diese selbe Normalität herzustellen und so ein stabilisierender Faktor zu sein, gerade vor dem Hintergrund, dass ja dann viele Richter wahrscheinlich auch das Problem hatten, dass sie sich ja dann der Öffentlichkeit gegenüber und den Alliierten gegenüber auch rechtlich ja dann fragen lassen mussten, warst du Teil des Apparates, der hier das Unheil gebracht hat oder warst du nur ein kleines Rädchen? Da muss ja im Prinzip auch sehr viel Angst da gewesen sein.
Flucht und andere Aspekte noch mit reinkommen. Wie stabil war denn der juristische Apparat, nachdem der Krieg dann auch offiziell verloren war?
Der hat dadurch eigentlich nicht weiter gelitten. Die Parteigenossen der NSDAP mussten sich natürlich rechtfertigen und mussten sich da dem berühmten Entnazifizierungsverfahren unterziehen. Innerhalb der Justiz waren das ich glaube 80-90%, durchschnittlich irgendwie 85 mit örtlichen Unterschieden. Aber wir wissen ja auch, dass die Entnazifizierung auf dem Niveau weitgehend gescheitert ist. Also Führungspositionen wurden da ausgetauscht. Der Gerichtspräsident, der Parteimitglied war, der konnte danach nicht mehr Gerichtspräsident sein, wurde dann aber irgendwann wieder eingestellt als normaler Richter. Wenn es ganz schlimm war an einem anderen Ort im selben Gerichtssprengel oder so. Also das weiß man ja, dass da nun keine furchtbar tiefgreifenden Veränderungen stattgefunden haben. Der, wie soll ich sagen, Apparat kann da relativ viel absorbieren. Der absorbiert dann auch die ganzen Flüchtlinge.
Also die Flüchtlingsjuristen aus dem Justizdienst in den verlorenen Ostgebieten, die werden dann irgendwann alle aufgenommen. Das ist dann irgendwann dieses G131. Aber der wird dadurch …
Was ist das G131?
Das ist nach Grundgesetzartikel 131, der den Beamten eine Wiederanstellung im öffentlichen Dienst garantiert hat. Und dazu wird dann später ein Ausführungsgesetz erlassen und dann werden die aus dem Justizdienst, spätestens dann, werden sie alle übernommen. Was dann diesen komischen Aspekt hat, dass man Ender 40er, Anfang der 50er Jahre ortsweise eine höhere Quote an Parteimitgliedern hat als während des Dritten Reiches selber. Weil man erst mal die Alten berücksichtigen muss, bevor man dann Neue anstellen kann. Und die faktischen Probleme, mit denen man zu tun hat, ändern sich durch die Kapitulation natürlich auch nicht so grundlegend. Man hat dann plötzlich diesen riesigen schwarzen Markt, den man vorher aber natürlich auch schon hatte. Jetzt findet er vielleicht etwas offener statt und kann auch offener thematisiert werden. Man hat sehr viele Eigentumsdelikte, also Diebstahl, Betrug, Hehlerei und so was. Aber man findet auch gelegentliche Hinweise darauf, dass die Situation im Krieg eigentlich, wie soll ich sagen, noch nicht so schlimm war.
Also dass beispielsweise jemand, der schwarz schlachtet, im Krieg 41/42 mit einer milderen Strafe rechnen muss, als 45 dann, als die Versorgungslage schlimmer ist und wenn man das im Rückblick betrachtet 46/47 und sich da irgendeiner rechtfertigen muss, warum er irgendjemanden zu so einer Strafe verurteilt hat, dann sagen die häufig, ja die Milde der Strafe ist dadurch zu rechtfertigen, dass 41 die Versorgung noch nicht so schlimm war. Und das kann man dann 46/47, als es wirklich schlimm wird und die Leute dann hungern, schwieriger plausibel machen.
Weil die Auswirkungen entsprechend gravierender sind?
Ja.
Aber auch hier ist sozusagen die Stabilität des Rechtssystems dann auch wiederum ein erheblich stabilisierender Faktor für das wieder auf die Beine kommen?
Ja klar. Das sehen ja auch die Alliierten so. Die Alliierten kommen, machen erst mal alles zu, aber haben selber das vitalste Interesse daran, dass die Justiz möglichst bald wieder auf die Beine kommt. Die kommen dann auch sehr schnell auf die Beine. Also in vielen Orten hier in Berlin ist Ende Mai die Justiz wieder am arbeiten. Die braucht wirklich 3-4 Wochen und dann hat man die Quartiere wieder bezogen, teilweise neue gefunden. Gesetzessammlungen zusammengesammelt aus den Ruinen. Andere Literatur. Hat unbelastete Juristen gefunden der allerersten Stunde. Teilweise dann natürlich auch belastete Juristen gefunden, mit denen man trotzdem irgendwie weiter operiert. Das geht überwiegend sehr schnell deshalb, weil die Leistungen, die die Justiz erbringt, unverzichtbar sind. Das ist die konkreten Entscheidungstätigkeit im Urteil. Bestimmte Dinge müssen in Rechtsförmigkeit übertragen werden, damit man damit irgendwie operieren kann. Aber häufig sind es auch eben ganz verwaltungstechnische Angebote, die da erbracht werden.
Also Grundbücher, die geführt werden, Register, Handelsregister, Genossenschaftsregister und so weiter, die müssen weiter bearbeitet werden. Wenn nicht, dann befürchten alle, versinkt man im totalen Chaos. Deswegen gibt es ein starkes politisches Interesse, das möglichst schnell wieder weiterzuführen und der Apparat ist, also ich will nicht sagen, intakt, das wäre zu übertrieben formuliert, aber der Apparat hat sehr viel weniger Blessuren abbekommen, als man angesichts der faktischen Zerstörung meinen könnte. Und deswegen kann man da auf Restbestände zurückgreifen, die in bestimmter Weise dann politisch neu justiert werden müssen, die aber als Bestand weiter Verwendung finden können.
Man könnte sagen, der Kopf des gesamten Systems ist komplett durchgedreht, aber der Körper hat eigentlich die ganze Zeit weiter funktioniert?
Ja.
Das heißt ich lese jetzt mal so raus, dass dann auch diese gesamte Entnazifizierung für den juristischen Bereich in der Zeit kein Problem war? Später, spätestens mit den 68er Studentenrevolten, kam das Thema ja dann nochmal verstärkt auf.
Ja das kann man chronologisch so sagen, allerdings muss man dann natürlich demographisch noch differenzieren. Wir haben bisher wahrscheinlich implizit eine westliche Perspektive eingenommen. Wenn man in die sowjetische Besatzungszone überwechselt, dann sehen die Verhältnisse natürlich anders aus. Die SMAD, die sowjetische Militäradministration Deutschlands hat sich das Ziel gesetzt und es auch durchgesetzt, alle Parteigenossen aus dem Justizdienst zu entfernen. Und das ist soweit ich weiß nahezu restlos geglückt. Also da werden immer wieder Listen geführt, ob da noch irgendwo einer sitzt und dann findet man gelegentlich noch so im gehobenen Dienst oder mittleren Dienst irgendwo einen und diskutiert dann, ob man den noch behalten kann oder nicht. Soweit ich weiß, hat es unter den Justizjuristen wirklich so gut wie gar keinen gegeben, der sich als Parteimitglied im Justizdienst in der SBZ noch halten konnte. Also dort findet tatsächlich ein radikaler Spruch statt mit den bekannten anderen Problemen.
Man muss dann irgendwie Ersatz herbeischaffen, den findet man natürlich nicht so schnell, deswegen werden dann diese Volksrichter in Schnellkursen ausgebildet und in anderer Art und Weise ideologisch vorbereitet auf Dienst am System. Aber im Osten hat man natürlich eine deutliche Zäsur was das Personal angeht. Was den Betrieb selber natürlich auch nicht notwendig verändert. Also im Osten werden anhängige Gerichtsverfahren genauso weitergeführt. Im Osten gibt es dann 47 eine Anordnung im gerichtlichen Verfahren, die es ermöglicht, die Gerichtsverfahren der verlorenen Ostgebiete weiterzuführen. Also da ist man sogar schneller, eben weil man mehr Flüchtlinge hat als im Westen. Aber die Vorstellung, dass der Apparat ein kontinuierlicher ist und Verwaltung nicht einfach zerstört werden kann, nur weil die Gerichtsgebäude zerstört sind und die entscheidenden Akteure weg sind, die findet man im Osten auch. Und im Westen klar, da kommt der Umbruch dann 68, wobei der sich justizintern dann wenig ausprägt.
Weil biografisch die meisten Fälle schon erledigt sind. Da sind sehr viele dann schon im Ruhestand.
Das heißt diese Entnazifizierung hat tatsächlich im juristischen System im Osten Deutschlands stärker gegriffen?
Ja da hat sie voll durchgegriffen.
Da hat sie voll durchgegriffen. Trotzdem lässt sich auch dort in dem Sinne kein Nachlassen der juristischen Aktivität feststellen?
Ja so kann man das sagen. Also auch die Sowjets haben ein ganz essentielles Interesse daran, dass der Betrieb wieder auf die Beine kommt. Und auch dort geht man prinzipiell von einem kontinuierlichen Strom der Verwaltung aus. Dort werden die Poltischen Spitzen viel radikaler abgeschnitten als im Westen. Also so Fragen, ich habe im Westen immer wieder damit zu tun, ob Urteile von Sondergerichten noch vollstreckt werden können. Und das ist eine Frage, also wenn einer im Krieg noch verurteilt wurde als Volksschädling, als Plünderer in einer Ruine nach einem Luftangriff oder so was, dann muss der im Westen damit rechnen, 46/47/48 noch immer wieder vorgeladen zu werden, vernommen zu werden, ob er damals noch verurteilt wurde, wenn ja zu welcher Strafe und dann wird man darüber debattieren, ob der noch einsitzen muss oder nicht. Volksschädling ist er nicht, aber ein Dieb ist er ja immer noch.
Und da gibt es dann Fälle, wo die dann irgendwie 46/47 nochmal ein paar Monate eigentlich einsitzen müssten und dann sagt man, gut das wird jetzt erlassen im Gnadenwege. Also heute würde man Bewährung dazu sagen. Aber da geht man selbst bei diesen hochpolitisierten Verfahren davon aus, dass es ausreicht, die politische Beimischung irgendwie rauszunehmen und der Rest bleibt dann erhalten. Und das findet man im Osten nicht. Also dass da Sondergerichtsurteile noch weiter vollstreckt werden könnten, das habe ich wirklich irgendwo gefunden. Also dass überhaupt nur einer auf die Idee kommt, da nochmal die Angeklagten vorzuladen und die wieder vor ein Gericht zu setzen und sie erneut dazu aufzufordern sich zu rechtfertigen für irgendwelche offensichtlich ideologisch motivierten Delikte, also die Formulierung der Delikte war ideologisch motiviert nicht die Begehung natürlich.
Das heißt so ein bisschen ist der Vorwurf des Ostens damals an den Westen, das man es sich sozusagen mit den Nazis doch ein wenig zu einfach macht, auch nicht so komplett falsch gewesen?
Nein der ist völlig richtig gewesen. Der ist nicht nur nicht falsch gewesen, sondern der ist völlig richtig gewesen. Wobei man den Vorwurf natürlich in zweierlei Hinsicht einschränken muss, zum einen muss man fragen, ob die Alternative, die man sich im Osten ausgedacht hat, nun wirklich die bessere war. Das ist teilweise mit hehrsten Motiven ins Werk gesetzt worden, aber auch schon sehr früh politisch völlig korrumpiert. Also dann mit dem Erfordernis wieder Parteimitglied zu sein, eben jetzt in der anderen Partei.
Also die Ideologie wurde ja nicht aus der Welt geschafft, sie wurde nur durch eine andere ersetzt.
Nein nein. Sie wurde durch eine andere ersetzt, und zwar schon sehr früh. Und ich bin sicher, dass es bei denen in der ersten Stunde häufig andere Pläne gegeben hat und man da wirklich sich versucht hat, an einen neuen Entwurf zu wagen, der aber sehr schnell dann auf eine andere schiefe Bahn gerät. Das ist die eine Einschränkung, die man machen muss und die andere wäre die Frage nach der Alternative, was man eigentlich hätte machen sollen. Und das weiß ich nun ehrlich gesagt auch nicht. Die Menschen waren ja nun mal da. Man hat dann diese 8 Millionen oder 8,5 Millionen Parteimitglieder. Ein riesiger Haufen in der Verwaltung und bei den Justizjuristen da sind unglaublich viele dabei, bei denen man in der Biografie nun nicht so furchtbar viele Dinge findet, die man heute beanstanden würde. Die sind Parteimitglied geworden, weil sie anders keine Karriere hätten machen können, weil sie die Familie ernähren wollten oder weil sie dies oder weil sie jenes tun wollen, haben sich mehr oder weniger politisch betätigt, manche exponierter, manche weniger.
Mit denen muss man ja nun irgendwas tun. Und man kann schlecht sagen, die sind jetzt alle 40, könnten noch 25 Jahre arbeiten, aber wir setzen die jetzt auf die Straße. Also irgendwas muss man denen anbieten und irgendwas muss man tun, sonst kann die neue Gesellschaft nicht funktionieren. Und da nun dann einfach den Vorwurf zu formulieren, ihr habt die weiter beschäftigt, das wäre zu einfach. Man müsste da schon sich irgendein Alternativmodell überlegen. Und ich muss gestehen, dass ich es auch nicht hätte.
Weil ja auch eine ganze Erfahrung und Ausbildung in diesen Leuten ja auch noch drinsteckt.
Klar.
Nicht nur, dass man mit denen klarkommen muss, wenn sie aus ihrem System raus sind, sondern dass auch das System dadurch enorm geschwächt wird.
Die Expertise von denen braucht man häufig auch.
Was lernt man jetzt aus dieser ganzen Betrachtung? Also allgemein haben wir es ja schon festgehalten, hier wird Normalität aufrechterhalten und diese Normalität wirkt als stabilisierender Faktor. Gibt es noch andere und darauf aufbauende Erkenntnisse, aus der Betrachtung dieser Zeit?
Also in historischer Hinsicht würde ich sagen, ist der Gedanke der Relativierung vielleicht kein schlechter. Das ist jedenfalls was, was ich lerne, die waren damals so wie wir. Das ist irgendwie was, was mich auch immer wieder verstört. Die waren so menschlich wie wir, die haben sich über ihre Nachbarn geärgert und haben die verklagt, haben ihre Prinzipien geritten und ihre Haare gespalten, so wie wir das heute vielleicht auch machen würden. Und das verstört mich zutiefst, weil ich immer die Leichenberge der Konzentrationslager vor mir sehe und dann nochmal vor Augen geführt bekomme, dass die, die das eine getan haben, auch das andere getan haben. Dass man sich davon also nicht leichtherzig distanzieren kann oder nicht einfach distanzieren kann. Also der berühmte Schlussstrich, den kann man deswegen nicht ziehen, weil wir so sind wie die und die so wie wir. Man kann die nicht in den moralischen Ausnahmezustand verweisen.
Und sagen, die waren eben böse oder die waren schlecht oder die waren eben anders als wir. Sondern wir scheinen uns auf einer ganz menschlichen basalen Ebene irgendwie zu begegnen. Also ich gucke in diese Akte und sehe mich sozusagen selber. Und das ist finde ich historisch jedenfalls für mich immer wieder verstörend. Ob man darüber dann hinaus für die Gegenwart auch noch was lernen kann, ist eine schwierige Frage. DAs hängt natürlich damit zusammen, ob man aus der Geschichte überhaupt irgendwas lernen kann. Ich bin da immer sehr skeptisch. Das wäre dann der alte bildungsbürgerliche Kampfruf, Historia Magistra Vitae, die Geschichte als die Lehrmeisterin des Lebens. Da habe ich immer ganz große Bedenken. Weil je länger man sich damit beschädigt, dann doch immer wieder oder immer weiter dazu kommt, dass die historischen Konstellationen auf ihre Art immer speziell sind und sich so Übertragbarkeiten eigentlich sehr schlecht etablieren lassen.
Je weiter man guckt, desto mehr muss man sagen, nein eigentlich passt es doch nicht, die Zeit war irgendwie anders. In Syrien werden Grundbücher zerstört, damals wurden auch Grundbücher zerstört, ist das irgendwie vergleichbar? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Die Gesellschaft ist eine andere, der Staat ist ein anderer. Die verwaltungstechnischen Voraussetzungen sind andere. Irgendwie passt es nicht. Wenn ich trotzdem daraus eine Einsicht formulieren würde, dann ist es die in die Komplexität der Welt. Und das finde ich angesichts der besonderen Entwicklung der Gegenwart keine allzu banale Einsicht. Wenn man einen Verwaltungsapparat hat und Tabula rasa machen möchte, auf den Tisch hauen als der starke autoritäre Mann, dann genügt es nicht, einen totalen Krieg zu entfesseln, alle Gebäude zu zerstören, in denen diese Verwaltung sitzt, das Personal an die Front zu schicken, in den Tod zu schicken, die Akten verbrennen zu lassen.
Der Apparat selber, der Aufbau der Gesellschaft selber ist so zählebig und so komplex, dass er sich solchen Eingriffen, solchen Zäsuren irgendwie widersetzt. Und das heißt übertragen auf die Gegenwart, dass es sich einfachen Lösungen widersetzt. Einfache Lösungen, so würde ich sagen, sind im Angesicht der Komplexität der Welt immer die falschen.
Kann man das auch auf heute übertragen?
Das würde ich ohne weiteres auf heute übertragen.
Gibt es da auch konkrete Dinge, mit denen man das jetzt so mal anwenden könnte?
Da verlasse ich sozusagen meine Kompetenz. Da kann ich als betroffener Staatsbürger antworten.
Das würde mir reichen ja.
Als Historiker oder Rechtshistoriker kann ich da natürlich nicht mehr zu sagen, als andere Leute auch dazu sagen können. Aber Populismus, vielleicht auch Nationalismus insgesamt sind einfach Antworten und einfache Antworten müssen falsch sein. Die Gesellschaft ist so komplex, die Welt ist so komplex und so unübersehbar, so vielschichtig, so aufgetürmt in ihren Eigenheiten und Besonderheiten, da kann man nicht mit einfachen Antworten kommen. Und es mag sein, dass die Politik eine besondere Verantwortung hat, komplexe Sachverhalte in einfach Antworten zu übertragen und sie verstehbar zu machen, sie dann mitunter auch zu reduzieren und plakativ zu machen und so weiter, das kann durchaus sein. Aber es kann nicht Programmatik werden. Wenn politische Programmatik sich auf Einfachheit, auf die Verweigerung von Komplexität stützt, dann muss sie die falsche sein.
Jetzt haben wir, um mal so ein bisschen auch in die aktuelle Zeit die Nase einzuhalten, schon heute noch eine besondere Bedeutung des Juristischen. Also ich denke, das was wir jetzt über diese Zeit am Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs gehört habe, gilt natürlich mehr oder weniger auch für unsere Zeit jetzt. Diese Normalität stabilisiert diese Gesellschaft, ob man es jetzt Rechtsstaat nennt oder nicht, aber allein dieses Systems des Aushandelns von Konflikten innerhalb der Gesellschaft in einem zumindest halbwegs funktionierenden Maße zu haben, man kann natürlich jetzt viel kritisieren über den Durchsatz und überhaupt und Trends etc. Aber grundsätzlich denke ich ist vollkommen unumstritten, dass das Rechtssystem ein Hauptfaktor in der Stabilisierung einer Gesellschaft.
Gäbe es das jetzt von heute auf morgen nicht, dann wäre gleich eine ganze Menge im Argen. Was sich derzeit ja so ein bisschen abzeichnet ist so diese Frage, inwiefern entzieht sich die Justiz auch diesen politischen Einflüssen. Wenn wir sagen, einfach Antworten helfen nicht weiter. Jetzt haben wir dieses komplizierte Rechtssystem, was ja dann aber auch trotzdem auch als politisches Korrektiv arbeiten muss, zumindest wenn es um Grundsatzfragen geht. Man sieht in den letzten Jahren, dass die Arbeit des Verfassungsgerichts sehr häufig sich mit Gesetzen auseinandersetzen muss, die erst vor Kurzem dann wieder beschlossen worden sind. Die vielleicht auch schon einmal oder zweimal vorher beim Verfassungsgericht behandelt worden sind. Was sind denn die Rahmenbedingungen, dass diese Justiz auch diese Leistung auch übernehmen kann, ein politisches Korrektiv zu bleiben?
Weil das war es ja jetzt am Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs in dem Sinne, zumindest in den betrachteten Fällen, nicht so sehr. Der Krieg spielte sich ab, der ganze Wahnsinn des Nationalsozialismus spielte sich ab, hat auch durchgegriffen auf den Apparat, aber der Apparat konnte nicht selber als Korrektiv fungieren, hat es nicht zurück beeinflusst. Derzeit haben wir glaube ich noch so ein bisschen dieses Spannungsfeld, dass die Unabhängigkeit des juristischen Systems doch ein starker Antipol ist für einfache politische Entscheidungswege. So nach dem Motto, das machen wir jetzt einfach mal, weil wir das jetzt mal machen können. Und dann kommt so das juristische System und sagt, ja nee so geht das aber jetzt nicht. Was ist dieser stärkende Faktor und ist der in Gefahr?
Der stärkende Faktor konnte sich damals natürlich nicht irgendwie ausbilden, weil der so nicht vorgesehen war. Man braucht dafür ein System, was auf Gewaltenteilung gründet und in dem sich die Politik auf Recht verpflichtet. Das war in Weimar schon sehr fragil im Dritten Reich sofort kassiert. Ab 33 spielt es keine Rolle mehr und ist so nicht vorgesehen und wird auch explizit so abgeschafft. Das will keiner mehr, jetzt soll ja endlich mit harter Hand durchregiert werden. Solche Fantasien findet man gegenwärtig natürlich auch immer wieder, das Durchregieren. Dass es dann schneller geht. Dann fragt man sich, ob Demokratien überhaupt noch in der Lage sind, bestimmte Entscheidungsprozesse zu einem Ende zu führen. Wenn man dann hier an so Großprojekte denkt, den Berliner Flughafen, den Stuttgarter Hauptbahnhof, wo jahrelang irgendwelche Festsetzungsbeschlüsse ergehen und dann am Ende erhebt sich das Volk und sagt, so wollen wir das aber dann doch nicht haben. Und sagt, furchtbar und Demokratie muss man die alle anhören und alle an den Tisch bringen und beteiligen und ist das nicht schlimm.
Wäre es nicht schön, wenn wir einfach wieder durchregieren könnten. Und in der Tat haben wir da eine Balance im Machtgefüge des Staates, die der Justiz in vielen Fragen die letzte Entscheidung zubilligt. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat da in gewisser Weise noch eine Sonderrolle, weil da die Politisierung von Anfang an eigentlich gewünscht war. Das ist irgendwie ein Fremdkörper, man definiert es ja gerne so, dass die Justiz eben der politikferne Bereich ist, der sich damit nicht auseinandersetzt. Und jetzt hat man eine Höchstinstitution, die explizit dafür geschaffen ist, auch politische Fragen zu entscheiden, und zwar einer rechtsverbindlichen Lösung zuzuführen und der Regierung selbst oder den eigentlich demokratisch legitimierten Entscheidungsträgern selbst, die Grenzen ihrer Handlungsspielräume aufzuzeigen. Das ist damals ganz bewusst geschaffen worden, natürlich auch als Antwort auf den Nationalsozialismus als letztes Korrektiv.
Ob das gegenwärtig in Gefahr ist, kann ich nur schwer sagen. Also einerseits natürlich ja, weil man diese Delirien hat, dass es so schön wäre, wenn man endlich mal wieder irgendwas machen könnte und endlich wieder irgendwas sagen dürfte. Andererseits sprechen die Fallzahlen und das internationale Ansehen, der Bedeutungszuwachs des Gerichtes irgendwie dagegen. Ich habe eigentlich eher den Eindruck, dass das Gericht in einer häufig wahrscheinlich unguten Art und Weise hineingezogen wird in den politischen Diskurs, dass man das, was man im Parlament nicht mehr mehrheitsfähig durchsetzen kann, dann irgendwie vor das Gericht trägt und sagt, gut wir akzeptieren hier die Niederlage bei der Abstimmung, aber wir verklagen euch dann später in Karlsruhe. Das ist dann sozusagen die Fortsetzung des politischen Diskurses mit anderen Mitteln. Eben mit justizförmigen Mitteln. Und das kann auf Dauer eigentlich nicht gesund sein.
Das müsste auf Dauer dann auch das Ansehen der Justiz oder des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes dann konkreter untergraben, und dafür mag es schon Anhaltspunkte geben, da bin ich aber wahrscheinlich nicht der richtige Beobachter, um daraufhin befragt zu werden.
Ist ja auch so eine Frage nach der potenziellen Modernisierung dieses Systems.
Ja gut. Das ist richtig. Das ist die Frage nach der Modernisierung.
Ich meine, ich habe viel Klage gehört am Anfang über Verwaltungsprozeduren und wie schädlich das ist und so diesen Aufbruch der Illusion, dass hier die Freiheit nicht mehr vertreten wird, jetzt sind wir ja eigentlich genau wieder so auf dem anderen Punkt angekommen. Passt das zusammen?
Ja ich bin da immer so hin und her gerissen. Also einerseits bin ich da ganz abgestoßen davon, wenn ich selber mal mich der Verwaltung ausgesetzt fühle und dann immer weiter irgendwelche Dinge ausfüllen muss und da hintragen muss und es reicht dann doch nicht und es wird noch gebeten, Beleg XY und die Geburtsurkunde und dies und jenes nachzutragen. Andererseits wenn ich nicht involviert bin und mich als Beobachter betätigen darf, muss ich wahrscheinlich anerkennen, dass es doch eine erhebliche zivilisatorische Leistung darstellt, die Lebenswelt in ihrer Zerklüftetheit so lange aufzuteilen und in Papierform zu bringen, bis man sich nicht mehr von Mensch zu Mensch gegenüber steht und ich weiß nicht mit körperlicher Gewalt über Dinge auseinandersetzt, sondern es eben in dieser Papierform tut. Und deswegen bin ich auch über die Schwergängigkeit und natürlich auch die Komplexität des Apparates überhaupt nicht erschreckt oder davon irgendwie aufgewühlt, sondern finde die eigentlich ganz wichtig, dass man sich in vielen Fragen Zeit nimmt.
Die Zeit auch, so was in eine bestimmte Prozedur zu übertragen und bestimmte Förmlichkeiten. Finde eigentlich auch gut, dass es immer noch so konservativ gehandhabt wird, Fernsehen zuzulassen im Gerichtssaal. Dass man also bestimmte mediale Sicherungen gegen die Echtzeit einführt und ganz deutlich signalisiert, dass das, was dort stattfindet, einen Eigenwert hat, der gerade darin besteht, dass man sich für einen Moment um den Rest der Welt nicht zu kümmern braucht. Und daraus wird dann bei mir natürlich in meinen eigenen historischen Akten eine gewaltige moralische Anklage, weil ich denke, jetzt kümmert euch endlich um den Rest der Welt. Geht doch da hinaus, seht doch, was in Auschwitz passiert, macht die Augen auf gefälligst und zugleich ist es in der Gegenwart, wo in der Welt natürlich auch dramatische Dinge passieren, aber es auch wenig nützen würde, sich jetzt permanent darum zu kümmern, mir immer wieder klar, welcher besondere Wert darin liegt.
Zivilisatorische Errungenschaft. Die Distanzierung oder Affektkontrolle. Man lebt sich dann nicht sofort aus, man greift nicht sofort zur hohen Gewalt, sondern begibt sich in die Arme der Justizförmigkeit.
Auch wenn sie einem manchmal ein bisschen nervt mit ihrem Verwaltungsfimmel, aber man bewundert in gewisser Hinsicht die Leute, die das dann trotzdem durchstehen, so was zu unterhalten, zu betreiben.
Ja. Also ich bewundere die Leute und ich finde es wichtig, dass dieser Dienst weiterhin bereitgestellt wird. Und natürlich auch von Akzeptanz in der Gesellschaft begleitet wird.
Was heißt denn das so für Ihre zukünftige Forschung? Ist das Thema jetzt schon durchgespielt? Was könnte denn ein anderer interessanter Bereich sein, in dem man entweder die Normalität nochmal aufrollt oder vielleicht etwas anderes vermutet? Gibt es vielleicht andere Länder, die man in dem Zusammenhang in den Kontext setzt. Das hatten wir ja vorhin schon kurz angesprochen, sozusagen dass es ja auch eine kulturelle Eigenschaft des deutschsprachigen Raumes ist, so zu agieren und sich selbige ähnliche Momente in anderen Ländern zumindest nicht in der Form so wiederfinden. Wohin könnte das gehen?
Also das wäre sicher ein interessanter Aspekt, der mich reizen würde. Das historisch zu vergleichen und zu untersuchen. Wobei da leider meine westliche Sozialisation etwas die Grenzen zieht. Also im westeuropäischen Ausland würde ich es mir zutrauen, im osteuropäischen sähe es schon sehr viel schwieriger aus, weil ich der slawischen Sprachen nicht mächtig bin und mir da auch nicht zutrauen würde, die auf in absehbarere Zeit auf einem Niveau zu erlernen, was da Archivrecherche ermöglichen würde. Deswegen sind dem relativ enge Grenzen gesetzt. Also wie es in Polen aussieht oder in Russland, Ukraine, das fände ich sehr interessant und kann es aber wahrscheinlich nicht untersuchen. Mehr interessieren würde mich wahrscheinlich auch der vergleichende Blick auf die Gegenwart. Wenn wir davon sprechen von Modernisierung des Gerichtssystems, dann ist es ja nicht nur die Art und Weise, wie ein konkretes Gerichtsverfahren stattfindet, soll man da dann auch twittern können während der Verhandlung oder irgendwie so was? Sollen die W-LAN bereitstellen und alles übertragen ins Internet? Darüber kann man ja nachdenken.
Man könnte aber natürlich auch darüber nachdenken, ob es nicht von Vornherein ganz andere Zugänge gibt, Konflikte irgendwie zu entscheiden. Also ein Stichwort, was gerade überall diskutiert wird wären die Schiedsgerichte. Natürlich internationale Schiedsgerichtsbarkeit, wie die sich nun eigentlich entwickelt hat, dass sie heute so ist wie sie ist, wie sie eigentlich konkret arbeitet. Darüber gibt es jetzt erst ganz umfassende Studien, aber die gibt es noch nicht so furchtbar lange. Also das finde ich interessant.
Wir reden jetzt von den Schiedsgerichten im Kontext von internationalen Handelsabkommen?
Ja genau. Weil die natürliche auch einen Modernisierungsdruck ausüben auf die deutsche Gerichtsbarkeit. So was nimmt man ja wahr. In manchen Gerichten beobachtet man oder in manchen Segmenten, dass die Fallzahlen rückläufig sind, was ganz eigenartig ist. Weil doch alles immer mehr wird und alles zunimmt, aber in bestimmten Fällen, ich glaube in bestimmten Formen des Arbeitsrechtes und anderen, also wirtschaftsrechtlich relevanten Bereichen beobachtet man, dass die Justiz weniger in Anspruch genommen wird. Was entweder dadurch erklärbar ist, dass weniger Konflikte auftreten, was man sich nicht so recht vorstellen mag, und deswegen dann vielleicht damit erklären muss, dass die Leute auf andere Formen der Konfliktbereinigung zurückgreifen. Also sich irgendwie außergerichtlich einigen oder Verträge schließen oder sich vielleicht vor internationalen Gerichtsbarkeiten verantworten. Schiedsrichter nennen, irgendwas anderes tun, Mediation. Und die Gerichte überlegen mitunter, wie sie da Schritthalten können. Also ob sie zum Beispiel Englisch als Sprache zulassen.
Dass es für international operierende Firmen attraktiver wäre, sich statt in Paris vor der Handelskammer vor dem Landgericht Berlin auseinanderzusetzen, weil man da plötzlich auf englisch verhandeln kann oder so was. Deswegen finde ich solche Bereiche interessant. Sie lösen in gewässerweise diese Richterzentrierung des deutschen Systems, alles ist auf Entscheidung gepolt und läuft darauf hinaus, auf. Weil man dann eben als ausgebildeter Jurist womöglich auch noch andere Dienste irgendwie bereitstellen muss. Oder damit leben muss, dass das Rechtssystem sich in einer Welt wiederfindet, in der diese Entscheidungsgeneigtheit kein Spezifikum des Rechtssystems selber ist, sondern in vielen anderen Segmenten auch stattfindet.
Könnte das vielleicht auch darauf hinweisen, dass, also wir haben jetzt gerade viele mögliche Antworten offen gelassen, aber könnte es vielleicht darauf hinweisen, dass vielleicht ausgehend von der Wirtschaft sich in der Gesellschaft eine andere Art und Weise entwickelt, Konflikte zu lösen? Sei es über das Vertragswesen oder sei es auch einfach nur durch eine andere Kommunikationskultur vielleicht auch?
Ja letzteres, also vertraglich habe ich gerade auch genannt, das ist aber natürlich eigentlich falsch. Vertraglich wäre ja auch eine Rechtsform, die man da wählt. Und die möchte ich dann sehen, wenn es da Streitigkeiten gibt über die Auslegung des Vertrages, ob man dann nicht letztendlich doch wieder vor Gericht landet.
Also vielleicht schon im Vertrag sehr viel mehr Mediation und Auswegsoptionen aufzeigt für solche Fälle, die sonst vielleicht sofort dazu geführt hätten, dass man klagt.
Ja das mag sein. Also Mediation wäre so ein Stichwort, womit ich mich aber noch nicht viel beschäftigt habe. Was jetzt ja komischerweise auch an Gerichten angeboten wird, obwohl man eigentlich mal gesagt hat, das hat mit Gerichten gar nichts zu tun, das soll was anderes sein. Also integrativer und partizipativer und eben gerade nicht auf diese binäre Kodierung hinauslaufen, ja oder nein, der oder der, dem wird was zugesprochen, dem wird nichts zugesprochen. Also da hat man ja schon so was anderes, was aber jetzt mittlerweile so ins Justizsystem auch integriert wurde. Dass Richter da Zusatzausbildungen bekommen und dann auch Mediation ausüben können. Vielleicht gibt es eine andere Unternehmenskultur, mag sein, die so was von Vornherein ausschließt oder vielleicht reduziert und einschränkt. Da kann man dann auch wieder fragen, ob es eigentlich besser ist, ob es dann vielleicht den Druck auf den Arbeitnehmer, der ja doch strukturell fast immer der unterlegene Teil ist, nicht doch irgendwie erhöht.
Ob der dadurch dann also eigentlich besser dran ist als vorher oder schlechter. Das kann ich alles nicht beantworten, das wären Fragen, für die ich mich interessieren würde. Also das wäre dann wirklich was gegenwärtiges, was die Geschichte dann verlassen würde oder die Geschichte eigentlich nur noch so als Folie hätte.
Oder jüngere Geschichte sozusagen.
Jüngere Zeitgeschichte.
Eben fiel der Begriff Innovationsdruck. Fand ich ganz interessant, durch diese Schiedsgerichte. Weil ja eigentlich in dem Moment, also sollte es jetzt tatsächlich so sein, dass die Schiedsgerichte sozusagen diese ganzen Fälle wegnehmen, die jetzt nicht mehr im normalen Justizsystem auslaufen, könnten ja alle sagen, super haben wir nichts zu tun, betrifft uns nicht. Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass die gleich alle nichts mehr zu tun hätten. Inwiefern ist das ein Innovationsdruck? Da gibt es ja in dem Sinne keinen Markt. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt Bar Charts aufstellt und sagt, oh wir haben 20% weniger Fälle zu verhandeln, wir müssen die Nachfrage stärken, so ist es ja nicht? Können sich doch eigentlich freuen darüber, dass es weniger wird?
Naja ein bisschen ist es natürlich schon so. Die Fallzahlen, die verhandelt werden, bestimmen den Stellenpool Und wenn die Fallzahlen dauerhaft rückläufig sind, dann werden die Stellen gestrichen.
Aber es klagen doch immer alle über totale Überlastung im juristischen System? Das kann ihnen doch nur recht sein, oder ist das auch nicht wahr?
Das kann ich nicht für alle Zweige gleichermaßen beurteilen. Das Sozialrecht ist notorisch überlastet durch Hartz IV. In vielen Bereichen des Zivilrechtes wird es wahrscheinlich anders aussehen, wobei man da vermutlich auch wieder sehr stark differenzieren muss, hier in einer großen Stadt wie Berlin, die notorisch unterfinanziert ist, da sind die natürlich alle überlastet. Auf dem platten Land geht es auch anders zu. Also das weiß ich nicht, ich meine schon, dass so was wahrgenommen wird, wenn bestimmte Segmente dauerhaft aus dem Justizsystem ausgelagert werden. Das nimmt man auch justizintern zur Kenntnis und nimmt es nicht nur freudig zur Kenntnis.
Weil es auch mit einem Bedeutungsverlust zu tun hat?
Es ist ein Bedeutungsverlust, also die konkrete Stelle, die eigene Stelle wird davon ja irgendwie nicht angegriffen, es ist ein Bedeutungsverlust und auf jeden Fall wird dieser Bedeutungsverlust gesellschaftlich übertragen auch an das Justizsystem. Der Bedeutungsverlust wird durch eine Übertragung der Gesellschaft auch im Justizsystem selber wahrgenommen. Nämlich dann, wenn dort Schiedsgerichte tätig werden als konkurrierende Institution, die einen anderen legitimatorischen Hintergrund haben. Also eben jetzt, was da immer diskutiert wird, dass die nicht öffentlich sind und dass man da keinen Einfluss hat auf die Richterwahl, dass da Staaten verklagt werden können, vielleicht ohne Blick auf das Gemeinwohl, das da womöglich demokratisch legitimierte Entscheidungen gekippt werden können von irgendwelchen obskuren Hinterzimmern. Das nimmt man sehr wohl wahr und je lauter der gesellschaftliche Druck wird, desto eher wird der auch im Rechtssystem wahrgenommen. Und desto eher wird da tatsächlich auch ein Modernisierungs-, ein Innovationsdruck als ein solcher wahrgenommen mit entsprechenden Anregungen.
Klingt wie ein Feld, was auch der Forschung nochmal ins Auge fallen könnte. Vielleicht auch mit einem etwas interdisziplinäreren Ansatz, als jetzt nur mit so einem historischen Blick. Weil ja hier eigentlich auch eine ganze Menge moderne Bewegung mit reinkommt. Sehr viele soziale gesellschaftliche Aspekte eine Rolle spielen, um solche Phänomene betrachten zu können. Ja das müsste man auf jeden Fall interdisziplinär machen. Aber da müsste man ja dann die wirtschaftlichen Kenntnisse haben, die Kenntnisse der Hochfinanz, wie das Kapital sich hin und her bewegt. Also ich alleine könnte eine Justizperspektive alleine nicht angemessen abbilden.
Das müssen wir jetzt auch nicht mehr machen. Jetzt haben wir auf jeden Fall über unser Thema viel gesprochen. Ich sage vielen Dank.
Benjamin Lahusen. Und das war er unser Ausritt in die juristischen Welten hier bei Forschergeist. Hier geht es auch bald wieder weiter mit einem neuen Gespräch. Und ich sage bis dahin, tschüss und bis bald.
Danke Ihnen.